but Zachary manages to like
[Music]
today we're gonna try and tell you guys
the plots of hocus-pocus without saying
the word like I do say like a lot I use
the word like basically I mean at least
like every other sentence like you heard
it right now
I used the word like in regular
conversation way more than I would like
to actually I use like all the time my
father loves to tell me this every time
he sees me my dad hates it when I say it
and I realized how much I say it when
I'm around him I would like to try and
stop saying it some people think it's
from clueless because you know old
valley girl thing I'm gonna say in a
million times this is not okay okay so
hocus-pocus the movie starts off with
three witches doing some bad stuff you
live in Salem and it's 16 something so
it starts off like there is a boy and
he's I don't know like they they take
his sister so he goes to try to save her
the witches steal her youth but hurry -
- like anyways they ended up draining
the life of little girls so that they
would look young then they did some sort
of spell so that they can come back on
Halloween they get hanged
just like witches would we're in Salem
again and it's the present-day
1993 and there's this new kid in school
he's from California he has a tight eye
t-shirt on he's tubular there's like
some kid no there's like some kid
there's this girl Allison hot chicken
class he's pretty confident here like
her face cool damn it he gets in there
asked her out she says no so they go
trick-or-treating no this is not enough
time there's some chick that he likes
and some people are making fun of
they go to the old house where the
witches were hanged they started looking
around he'd light some candle
they get brought back to life they burst
through the door they try to take Danny
I think or something then the black cat
comes I'm doing quite well now and
basically there's this entire new like
there's this entire new plot where the
Sanderson sisters are trying to like
it's really art where the senders and
sisters are trying to beep that was
horrible they tried to tell everybody
and they put the witches on blast and
try to show it but then the witches
getting all I got nowhere that was
really hard
my excited levels basically are like
peaking right now cuz it's so hard and I
had what I say it like five times
oh my god okay I said everything so
slowly that was loose disjointed awful
plot summary I've ever done in my entire
life so I think I only said it once I
used to be so much better at talking
eloquently I do want to be able to talk
more eloquently or without hitting a
wall where I feel like I have to say
like in order to breathe again I think
it's texting blaming this on texting
[Music]